hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to berry big knees now this
is just a demo like most of these indie
horror games are but this one is
absurdly highly reviewed and I don't
know if that's just because it just came
out recently or if there's actually
something to this terrifying game
although whether it's terrifying or not
I will leave up to my own judgement
well faulty wiring is always a good
start in these horror games hi is that
the moose man cuz I haven't heard the
moose man's call in many a year I don't
know what my mouse just went over
something's over there something's over
there can I do something about No okay I
can't take a seat I didn't even know
that was there that was a guess can I
hide in here do I need to hide
oh just decided to stretch of it it was
a good time I wanted to warm up before
this game got underway anyway did
something happen Wow where did I go I
think I got turned around but I'm not
sure oh okay we're off to a voluptuous
start okay is that supposed to be an
indication of danger or where I'm
supposed to go into how urgently I'm
supposed to go there I should follow the
trail oh let me stop myself and follow
down the arrow that I thought I was
gonna need to go down okay so what else
have you got for me in terms of the
cheap jump scare realm of possibility
seem to be in an old communists bunker
but what does that mean for me yeah and
also why what the [ __ ] was that oh yeah
yeah it's so goopy yeah it's goopy why
is it goopy it was so goopy someone
popped out before
it seems to be angry at something
probably me for disturbing its beauty
sleep okay that's not a good sound whoa
whoa it's still coming I didn't even
know who's gonna be coming after me [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] off dude he's getting close
he's getting way too close huh what I
couldn't read that the door is damned I
should get a crowbar I don't know where
a [ __ ] crowbar is hey I'm smooth I
don't know where crowbar is I barely
found a flashlight house by pure chance
[ __ ] am I gonna find a crowbar do I got
to go back so now oh I got to go back
don't I don't know where I got damn
crowbar is nothing's gonna get me I
don't know what its gonna do to me when
it gets me but it's gonna get me it's
got goopy neck tentacles ah what are you
doing what are you doing huh
what are you doing you wanna fight well
then oh I guess I [ __ ] it didn't I
goddamn it I don't know where the
goddamn crowbar is okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go back through
this and I'm gonna try to find the
crowbar beforehand and then not get
scared by the gym scare okay so it's not
in any of these so I'm Willy woo I'm
willing to bet that the crowbar is in
this room that the guy is in right now
the only problem with that is I don't
know how to get down here without him
coming to kill me you know what I mean
because it's very narrow hallways and
there's not a lot of room to get away so
but I bet I bet I'd be willing to bet
money that that is exactly where it is
and I believe I might be able to lose
him on these stairs and then going
around that way but we shall see I
it's gonna be enough space though
there's not a lot of room to run but if
I need it I've got it
hey hey hey hey hey ba ba ba ba goddamn
it Bubba Bubba found me okay so if I go
up here I might be able to swing swung
around quick enough before he can get me
and then get down in their room and then
getting out it's gonna be another
problem did you go back down ah [ __ ]
honey honey honey oh hi okay there it is
yeah yeah you're so gross
yeah so big - what's he so big and
bulbous is he actually gonna come up
here this time
goddamnit he's guarding it okay maybe I
gotta go over here and trigger the the
oh I need a crowbar dialog and then
that'll make it actually appear because
I hate to do all that and did not
actually be there okay so doors jammed I
should find a crowbar somewhere so I can
get back now before it cuts me off hey
hey hey oh no oh that did not go the way
that I wanted it to go [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
I'm good no not good yet mm-hmm [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
okay that's right you better back off
buddy boo Bubba Bubba Bubba Bubba full
of trouble I'm gonna go for it good I
don't think you noticed I don't think
you noticed I don't think you noticed
okay so it's gotta be in here somewhere
right
it's the only logical place for a
crabber oh [ __ ] it's not down here
[ __ ] where where's a crabber okay okay
so I actually had to look this up the
[ __ ] I can't I okay there we go yeah
okay so I had to look this up
it sounds bad how close is he he's right
nearby
oh okay where was he okay so I had to
look that up there are actually keys in
there and I don't know I missed it
because I figured there would be
something in that room or he spawned in
but there are keys down there and the
keys opened a door that then leads to
the crowbar now I don't know how anyone
would have been expected to understand
that he's around here somewhere
damn you're blocking my path Bubba come
on hurry up
move along you're already dead you're
just a floating ad whoa oh Jesus he
heard me insulting him he didn't like
that very much
okay so he's coming and slip by him come
up here come up here come up here come
up here my boo oh [ __ ] god damn it
that's not how I wanted that to go I
keep missing those stairs they're
thinking about dusters yeah yeah body
yeah body okay so that yeah here so now
this opens it didn't even have dialogue
or anything like that and somewhere in
here there's a crypt there it is the
core bear creek crab our crib are there
we go rhubarb oh it's like half life
except instead of holding and I'm
picking up in front of me with a gravity
gun anyway okay critter there
yeah not exactly how you'd use a crowbar
in that situation yeah okay good
yes we're free maybe free we don't we
don't we don't we don't seem very free
are we oh the big lever Yes No maybe so
no oh I had to click on the actual
device another level
okay so what did that do
what do they do
what did that stretches you know final
stretches for the end of the game okay
so that was interesting not perfect but
still it got me good on some certain
areas mostly just from jump scares but
even even so it was still pretty good
and what's even more amazing is I'm not
sure if this is true I read somewhere
that the developer this game is 13 years
old now I don't know if that's true
that's just what I heard that might have
been someone in the comments trying to
insult the developer I have no idea but
it was highly rated and actually very
let me let me confirm this before I
start spouting about that okay yes it
said in the description of the game on
gamejolt this was made by someone who's
13 years old and no matter what way you
slice it that's pretty impressive
someone who is 13 is already starting
and making games and this is put
together it's not perfect it's not
polished but it's pert together and it's
pretty interesting like not terribly
interesting mind you but it's got some
potential there and it's even more
impressive knowing that the developer is
so young so take that for what you will
I find it very impressive and I like
this game a lot so let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
give the developers some support and
encouragement for making more stuff in
the future and in a few years who knows
what they'll make so thank you so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]